[Musique]
quand on traverse le magnifique lac kivu
difficile d'imaginer qu'on est ici au
coeur d'une région en guerre depuis plus
de 20 ans depuis le génocide au rwanda
juste à côté
l'est du congo abrite des dizaines de
milliers de réfugiés de déplacer une
multitude de groupes armés va entendre
des souffrances normes 20 ans où les
enfants des bébés ne peuvent pas être
tranquille
j'entends ou le femmes ont peu de
l'allemand
[Musique]
après des études en europe le médecin
s'installe dans une région isolée de
l'est du congo quand son petit hôpital
est attaqué ses collègues presque tous
assassinés
denis mukwege il revient chez lui à
bukavu où ils ouvrent l'hôpital pam dit
en 1999 sa première patiente n'est pas
celle qu'il attendait quand on a opéré
la prime aux femmes
cette femme il était venu puisque à s'en
remettre dit si elle était attaquée
violée puis on m'a tiré sur son appareil
génital elle avait des blessures graves
avec deux fractures les cas de viols
occupe rapidement tout son temps le
gynécologue opère des lésions vaginales
qu'il n'avait vu dans aucun livre de
médecine parce que au fur et à mesure
que j'écoutais les histoires ça devenait
insupportable insupportables voire une
femme blessée de cette façon et
volontairement après avoir été violée
j'ai perdu tout simplement la capacité
de compte ce n'est pas compréhensible
dix ans plus tard le médecin cherche
toujours à comprendre ces viols sauvage
quand il reçoit une patiente beaucoup
trop jeune je ne pouvais pas imaginer
pas une seule seconde que un adulte peut
prendre un bébé de 18 mois et pénétrer
ses bébés et quand je vois et les
lésions qui les bébés avaient le rectum
le vagin et la vessie les intestins qui
sortait
je crois que pour moi c'était trop je
trouvais qu'ils sont des atrocités que
les animaux ne font pas
beaucoup appris
tout le monde avait fondu en larmes
quand elle avait 7 ans les enfants non
mais c'était catastrophique ont aidé
mais erronée des femmes sept médecins a
vécu la guerre mais elle n'avait jamais
vu la souffrance qu'elle a découverte à
l'hôpital du docteur mukwege j'étais
touché dans mon intérieur par une
douleur une peine en fait quelque chose
de très grave en fait je n'avais pas
conscience de ça mais je ne me pression
que l'homme aiguë elle manque
sinon docteur mon cahier pour moi c'est
une inspiration
parfois nous mêmes les femmes on est
assez sceptique on pose des questions on
a peut-être des préjugés mais lui l'ena
les bras ouverts en fait ils feront tout
le monde et puis il s'oublie lui-même
donc il a une telle dévotion et c'est au
moment d'attaquer les villages qu'ils
ont séjourné l'enfant cette jeune mère
travailler aux champs quand des hommes
armés ont attaqué la maison où sa soeur
garder son bébé de sept mois
10 min dans non ma côte ouest qui font
rouler on a pas que tous les canadiens
[Musique]
première fois que le docteur mukwege a
opéré un bébé comme la petite thérèse il
a décidé que soigner ne suffisait plus
comment je pouvais rester au bloc
opératoire
quand j'avais soit ni la mère sa fille
et sa fille
quelques temps après je soigne le bébé
de cette fille jure violet aussi je
pense que pour moi c'était trop fallait
vraiment
faire quelque chose des familles fally
averti relayant ce qui se passe le
médecin décide de raconter les horreurs
qu'il voit au quotidien
convaincu que le monde ne pourra rester
indifférents ou bébé de 7 mois que je
peux vous montrer ici violer je crois tu
que la ville de montréal dirais non il
faut faire quelque chose ce n'est pas
acceptable
est ce que nous sentons que nous
partageons la même humanité pour dire ça
pourrait être ma fille ma femme je
n'acceptais pas donc je m'indigne et
j'agis qu'est ce qu'il faut le médecin
devient une icône en faisant le tour du
monde pour dénoncer les violences
sexuelles devenue endémique dans son
pays
cette visibilité déplaît aux autorités
congolaises
depuis qu'on a tenté de le tuer il vit
sous haute surveillance à l'hôpital où
il opère encore jour et nuit
quand il n'est pas occupé à recevoir le
prix nobel de la paix j'ai moi même un
smartphone ces objets contiennent des
minérais contre où j'ai souvent extraits
dans des conditions inhumaines par des
enfants jeunes qui sont victimes
d'intimidation et des violences
sexuelles
[Applaudissements]
stan pour les justifier
tous les matins débute par une cuillère
à panzi qui est beaucoup plus qu'un
hôpital pour ces femmes c'est une oasis
qu'elles ne veulent pas quitter même une
fois guéri c'est que la majorité
provient de village minier où les
violences demeure un fléau
même quand les conflits armés ça pèse
est-ce que des fois vous êtes découragé
parfois je peux être en colère je me dis
mais ceci c'est pas c'est pas
compréhensible ce que je viens de vous
dire mais pas question de se décourager
dit le chirurgien de 64 à ce serait
donner raison aux barbares qui font de
cette exploitation humaine
tu apprends le français à chaque matin
quand il se lève il a hâte de retrouver
ses patientes qui lui donne la force de
continuer et je peux vous dire madame on
sait qu'il est très touchant c'est
lorsque vous resterez famille ici à
l'hôpital et que vous vous le voyez dans
un état de détresse de de souffrance de
pauvreté extrême mais qui après les
avoir soigné avec un minimum auquel on
vous trouvez qu'il retrouve le sourire
qu'elles sont prêtes à aller dé l'avant
pour pouvoir faire beaucoup pas pour
elle-même mais pour les autres je me
sens toujours métier je me dis mais ces
femmes quelqu'un qu'est ce qu'elles ont
à nesles
l'atout doivent le pousser à 7,1 bâti
extrême